first things first congratulations Dad
oh thank you a newborn you're back in
newborn territory back in the game baby
what does it look like no I was quite
Young when I had my first you know
daughter still you know 29 so you know
now 46 so you're 29 yeah so 46 you know
is now a whole different ball game but
it's cool you can enjoy things that
stressed you out before you know crying
and being up all night and the
restlessness I'm used to all that like
you know the the Knights of like passing
out and waking up going I literally
don't remember the last 10 hours what a
great night's sleep I literally haven't
had that since 2006. I loved your
reaction when you were like you were 29
when you had kids yeah I know how do the
two of you feel about you know little
Dylan Like does it give you at all the
baby fever well yeah not so much Annie
yeah I mean yeah
a little bit I mean I we've talked
because you always wanted to raise kids
together yeah the cousins yeah so you
know maybe this time around I'll be able
to jump in because the first time Joe
you know was younger and I was younger
and I I just didn't have kids in that
phase of my life so maybe this time
around we can get in sync and we're
actually going to be talking about
things and and relating the way we
actually do in real life no one's ever
seen that no scripts just us right Matt
getting to watch this podcast even after
one episode I feel like I know you guys
individually now a little bit cool the
reptile thing it is fascinating to me I
think because it's not every day that we
meet like a reptile expert yeah yeah so
tell me a little bit about your reptile
family how big is it and extensive yeah
um yeah I'm I I do a lot of the babies
are just the babies things like that
whenever they have the the kids I don't
necessarily name all the kids also
because I have to park with them and
it's tough that's the hardest part no
name on the bus that'd be weird
so so
yeah well see I'm not just there there's
a purpose to it you know there's a lot
of these so reptiles sir gentlemen sorry
we're talking reptiles sorry sorry come
on he doesn't name all the kids there's
like 40 of them when they're born can
you imagine
yeah I've got a lot of iguanas tortoises
uh bearded dragons things like that but
I there's a purpose to it when they get
sick it's a good indicator to the health
of the environment so these species we
need to work with because we're losing
them rapidly so a lot of these animals
that I have are ones that I'm captive
breeding so we can take the demand off
the wild populations and also help them
so there's a purpose to it all listen I
thought this was just a hobby you're a
full-blown conservationist yeah I love
it yeah really it's I was born with it I
don't know why but when I look at little
reptiles amphibians the same thing
people get when they see a little puppy
or something I get that like little
feeling inside you know yeah look it
makes me so happy to see you with such a
big smile on your face talking about
your passion for reptiles you're with
your brothers you're doing this podcast
it feels like you're in a really full
moment right now yeah you and your girl
chili I mean my goodness how happy are
you yeah my life is is in complete Bloom
right now now I get to hang out with
these guys I get to spend time with the
amazing woman like chili I've never
gotten to be able to experience that
kind of a relationship before so it's
it's quite special she's really really
special human being I wish more people
on the planet would like her we'd be
much better off you are you are lighting
up right now talking about her what what
is it that sets her Apart Her morals and
her values the way she treats her family
she loves my family it's so important we
get along like she's like okay we'll
talk to the folks like my mom's calling
me like go get it I know how important
that is same thing like my mom calls me
it's not like you know why are you
talking to your mom it's like oh your
mom oh go go talk to your mom right I'll
peel back we just we we it's weird you
know we we have similar upbrings we have
similar families there are similarities
that you wouldn't necessarily think
between us and it really works so so she
loves your family yeah and I love hers
too great great family have you met her
son yes yes challenge he's so cool so
cool I know I know and he's getting in
shape right now and he's just yeah he's
he's like making me feel like I can
start doing push-ups and stuff listen
maybe he gets you in the gym yeah
[Applause]
oh God Joey can't come on I know I know
you guys it seems like you've been lucky
enough to spend some time with her yeah
awesome she's awesome she's awesome
yeah she's really cool really I can't I
can't explain it she's so sweet and so
wonderful yeah she's really she's really
really cool yep can I ask how you guys
met
yeah we met uh we were just uh working
together and we met at one of these
events working together yeah we were at
least events where she was performing
and I was doing like a like a q a type
of thing I got it we met in passing and
it was just real friendship for you know
like five or six months just just
talking on the phone long distance like
getting to know each other seeing each
other here and there but really just
keeping it friends and being you know
let's let's keep our priorities straight
here we want to know you know what we're
all about we don't want to take this too
fast excuse me for divulging your
personal information but didn't you guys
like wind up on the same plane or
something oh yes you're right okay so
that sounds like face even that stuff I
really do this is this is like we were
all scattered Matt was like emergency
leaving or something and then this is
very true I talked to him when he landed
he was like you're not going to believe
it I met like the most wonderful person
I was sitting behind her we had met yeah
so so we so we were at this thing we
were working we just said hello and the
passing and probably nothing would have
come of that but there was this big
snowstorm I had to be back for work so I
was getting them to change my flights
all around the only flight I could get
was a connecting flight through Atlanta
she lives in Atlanta she was lying on
that flight so really it was the flight
talking and then afterwards saying hey
you know what let's keep in contact
that's really what made it and it almost
did not happen I mean literally an hour
before the flight took off they were
like okay we got you on this light you
gotta go
so it's just like that there it is I
think do you call her chili yeah I I do
I started it's weird I started out
calling her chili but really I mean what
do you guys call it well I call her
chili but I promise I say the word chili
sauce oh yeah I'm like oh God it's so
chilly in here
it's chilly outside
and she always looks and I'm like no I'm
in the room it's chilly season yeah it
is chilly season up here I'm hoping we
get her as a guest on the podcast
that idea I've been floating
around you can throw it around for sure
yeah we're definitely thinking about
working together for sure you said
earlier that you know the idea of being
able to all raise kids together that's
so special yeah do you feel like that's
in the cards for you in the near future
I I hope that's that's the game plan
yeah you know that's what we're trying
to do you know before we get too old
before we get too old yeah is that what
Chili's trying to do yeah hey you know
I'll let I'll let I'll let her speak
first okay we've got married and happy
we've got really happy where it is
like listen I'm just gonna point out he
did come in all black yes I do wear a
lot of black where do you stand in all
of this are are you do you have someone
special I I am I am I am single at the
moment but I'm not uh I'm not closed off
but not forgotten what the hell are you
providing me a uh someone special you
know that would be great if I want to
meet that person and it works it works
maybe you need to go to a convention
apparently yeah yeah right yeah yeah
it's true cannot trust you you cannot
trust anybody these days that's right
well we can trust somebody
right each other right here the circle
of trust for the most part the circle of
trust for the most part let's just
rewind a little bit how does the
Brotherly Love podcast even come about
for years it's like would you guys do a
reality show right and you know and
honestly we've explored certain Avenues
and venues and none of it felt right
none of it worked it's all about it's
all very salacious based for the most
part and that's not who we are you want
to protect your piece but that's just
not who we are no and then we developed
a a half hour comedy actually
um called Lawrence house with the
producer of Wedding Crashers and it's
unbelievable and that'll be out later
this year that's a scripted series they
were hoping single camera it's really
cool so is this is this new information
it's very new it's fairly new yeah I
didn't know he was even going to be
talking about this no yeah it's new so
we thought well maybe this is sort of
ins like we'll never do the reality
route but this is kind of actually a
glimpse into our lives yes yes it's come
to us it's like it's like a podcast
about nothing it's a table conversation
you know because I failed a podcast yeah
it's Julie we were thinking why don't we
do a podcast about nothing no I mean
selflessly so that was why I was so
excited about this podcast is because it
was an excuse for me to sit around a
table Yeah and talk to my brothers and
get to hang out with them right that's
something and we're doing it more than
we have in a long time yeah people are
already going like I had no idea you
guys literally roast each other like
that all the time you're ruthlessly yeah
ruthlessly if I'm not working working I
try to shower like two times a month a
week perfect three times a week Matt's
armpits uh smell like a drive-through at
a fast food restaurant double double and
Fries yeah protein style guys oh nice
perfect not even a sweet bun to mask the
smell and the best part is that I feel
like after a really like deep dig or a
deep burn you're like laughing 0.5 40
seconds later and you're hugging it out
there is no yeah there is no uh there's
no animosity in fact there's admiration
yeah how good it is
a little please exactly that hurt me
good job
uh yeah
foreign